this week tech entrepreneur Elon Musk
posted a video update of his latest
project a tunnel beneath Los Angeles the
first of several he wants to build to
alleviate the city's traffic problems
the same day another member of his
family made headlines when Iman's
younger brother Kimball raffled off his
own model 3 Tesla to raise more than two
million dollars for his nonprofit group
Big Green Kimball musk has been working
to increase food literacy among the
nation's school kids and to increase
access to fresh wholesome food for
people everywhere Barry Petersen has his
story do you remember why they need to
be planted underneath this they need the
shade and they taste better if they're
suffering on a crisp Denver morning
these middle school students are
discovering how to develop a green thumb
there we go beautiful you get your hands
into the soil and start planting arugula
chard and kale is this experience going
to kind of change how you think about
chewing on these Denver School of
Science and Technology students is the
man in the straw hat he's no ordinary
cowboy
he's Kimball musk in the 90s he helped
older brother Elon launch zip - and the
company that would become PayPal so many
people told me back 2000 2002 to them
five I missed the opportunity for the
internet and I look to them and said yep
you missed it
it was awesome real food is the
opportunity of your generation the wave
that is coming will blow your mind
what does that mean real food is the new
internet means that young entrepreneurs
getting into food today
where they're bringing real food that
just tastes much better that's food that
you trust to nourish your body trust a
nourish the farmer and trust in ours to
planet
is the opportunity of our generation
mosque still works with his brothers
ventures Tesla and SpaceX but this is
his personal venture that's become a
life's work replacing high-calorie foods
with healthier ones let's try that one
it is M brochure it is really good this
is a nutritious delicious kill chip that
kids love it's fried though right it is
fried but it's super nutritious it's the
most nutritious vegetable out there so
it's it's an alternative to french fries
that kids just love musk always had an
interest in cookie attending culinary
school after making it big intact but in
2001 he found purpose in tragedy
I graduated from cooking school just
before 9/11 I woke up to the sounds of
the planes hitting the building I live
right close to the World Trade Centers
and looked out the window saw the Towers
fall escaped that area was really
intense and and one of the hardest
things I've ever been through but in
that process I got invited to volunteer
for the firefighters it taught me the
power of community taught me that how
food brings communities together how
real food in can revitalize people even
in the most traumatic circumstances
alongside his business partner Hugo
Mathison musk opened his first
restaurant the kitchen in 2004 after
rave reviews the kitchen expanded to the
kitchen Restaurant Group serving up
high-end dining at hedgerow an
affordable farm-to-table dishes at next
door so the restaurant is kind of
papered with these signs like eat local
food what does that mean so local to us
primarily means knowing your farmer and
trusting where your food comes from and
for us at next door that means a farmer
gets to know us directly so they drive
here we get to know them we medical
visit their farm but you really kind of
competing with one dollar hamburger
meals
trying to encourage people to eat kale
chips instead you know you'll be amazed
at how expensive those places actually
are you know if you go to McDonald's on
a family of four you can spend 30 bucks
we're not competing with McDonald's in
price but we're easily at Applebee's or
chilled Chili's pricing so for a family
of four you might be at forty bucks
over time we hope to get that even
cheaper and musk wants to make sure no
matter where you live a farmer is never
too far away he's trying to make that a
reality with this brooklyn start-up
called square roots these rows of
shipping containers are vertical urban
farms that fit two acres of outdoor
growing space into 320 square feet Ryan
Commerce is one of ten entrepreneur
farmers at square roots so our farm is
geared towards more wholesale we sold to
mainly restaurants so half of my farm
this entire half of the farm is just
kale and so we're able to produce Justin
in this farm about 30 pounds of kale
each week with the number of American
farmers declining steadily musk isn't
just investing in the technology to move
fernand into the future but in future
farmers themselves in 2011 musk
co-founded his nonprofit big green
bringing edible and educational
nourishment to schools that need it most
so the idea behind the learning gardens
is to connect kids to real food and I'll
take that back to their home they may
get their parents to buy more nutritious
food at the grocery stores but they'll
make better decisions for the rest of
their lives around real food we're not
here to tell them what to do but we want
them to know what real food is
Big Green is currently serving 460
thousand students in seven states in the
hope is to reach 1 million children by
the year 2020 dear the sense when you're
around these kids that they don't even
know like where food comes from
unfortunately yes
when we meet them for the first time we
build a learning garden for the first
time I would say I'm Tom says as much as
90% of the kids have never put their
hand in soil Wow have never pulled a
carrot out of the ground have never
grabbed a cherry tomato off its vine and
when they do do that and they try it for
the first time it's like a magic trick
for them it's just wow they're their
senses come alive they understand what
real food can taste like awesome and for
kids like eighth grader Paige Davis musk
is planting the seeds of passion for
real food so have you ever had Garden
food as opposed to grocery food like a
fresh tomato what's the difference to me
this sounds weird but like it's happier
and it just makes me happy to think that
someone enjoyed planting that tomato and
then I'm eating like a whole to an old
truism you can be what you eat it's good
for CBS this morning Saturday Barry
Petersen Denver Colorado a happier
tomato says goofy but there's a point I
know it feels like I've been eating fake
food most of my life
[Laughter]